what are your impressions of kyler
murray's throwing ability now that
you've been with him up close a little
bit
and kyla has armed
you know obviously i'm i'm thankful to
play with a quarterback like that that
can make any throw anywhere on the field
and has confidence to do it
and i think just from from what i've
seen
you know we're going to have a good time
playing football together
deandre hopkins from last week talking
about kylie murray first overall pick in
the 2019 draft
and uh we expect a big jump from him
in 2020 maybe not a huge jump for the
cardinals organization because they're
in a tough division i got him at number
20 going into the season chris but i
believe in this team i think this team
is playoff ready i think deandre hopkins
makes a huge difference i do think tyler
murray is going to have the same kind of
kind of emergence that we saw in patrick
mahomes second season lamar jackson's
second season i feel like kyle murray is
going to continue that this year
and uh you know if they were in any
other division they may be the favorite
to win it they just happen to be stuck
with the seahawks the 49ers and the rams
well they're one of the more intriguing
teams in football now do i think you've
overrated them a little bit in your
power rankings yes i do like i um you
know i mean full transparency would i
have put them in front of the rams or
the chargers no probably not quite quite
yet but like my excitement level does it
match yours yeah i think it does and i
mean of course that starts with the
quarterback yeah you've you've been all
over it we're expecting a mahomes type
explosion i understand that you know he
seems wise behind his uh wise beyond his
years or ears whatever the hell that is
i forgot i've been saying years forever
uh but either way i'm digging uh but
either way with that you know they're
starting to
get a hopkins you know the kendra the
kenyan drake trade last year they
formulated a group of players that fit
the skill set of the quarterback and
then also fit the skill set that's
needed to execute the cliff kingsbury
scheme and that's what i think is
exciting and that's the same on the
defensive side of the ball you know the
defense stunk last year it was the worst
in football you could do whatever you
want but
there's some young talent there you know
along with chandler jones that you go oh
i'm excited about that you know and did
a good job in free agency so there's
certainly optimism mike and uh you know
i think it all does start with the guy
you talked about that's kyla murray
because we're expecting superstar type
performance from him this year
yeah i really am and and and look i i
mean it when i say that they would be
you know favorites in most of the other
divisions if we assigned them to
something well and i wouldn't say most
they wouldn't be the favorites in the
afc north or the west i'd put him as
favorites in the afc east i'd put him as
favorites in the afc south or at least
close to it uh they're they are quietly
putting something together that that
could work this year the problem is they
also could be in fourth place in their
own division did you just say one of the
favorites and the afc's did you just say
that over the patriots yeah
you would you're crazy
you're crazy you're crazy where do you
have the bills and the patriots ranked
in your power rankings so so why didn't
you have them ahead
go ahead
can i can i finish can i finish i like
calamarium wise behind my ears i uh
as you would say i put them at number 20
and them at number 20 because of the
division they're in if they're in
another division they'd be higher that's
one of the factors they're going to have
a hell of a time
navigating their own backyard before
they can compete with anyone else i look
i i think last year
they we we just overlooked the cardinals
because it was seahawks and 49ers and
rams we didn't see kyler murray very
much if at all on a big platform right
we didn't get a chance to appreciate
what he could be
if they would have been trapped in that
division last year they may have been a
playoff contender so i i just i'm trying
to project what this team would be if it
didn't have to deal with the 49ers twice
a year in the seahawks twice a year in
the rams twice a year although they did
beat the seahawks in seattle when
seattle was still playing for the
division title so i think there's a lot
of potential and promise there at the
andre hopkins trade
it's just i think it's one of the most
overlooked big time trades we've had in
years where you just have to remind
yourself oh yeah they have deandre
hopkins now i mean it's easy to remember
the texans don't have him
it's hard to remember that the cardinals
do
and it's going to be easy to remember
once he starts generating big numbers
and opening things up for larry
fitzgerald and christian kirk and the
running lanes for kenyon drake and and
all of a sudden this team starts uh
starts doing the things that we both
expect them to do chris well yeah i mean
to me the the the players that you just
mentioned along with the quarterback and
then what we saw from cliff kingsbury
listen you know full transparency yeah
cliff kingsbury was a huge question mark
for me going in the 2019 season yeah
okay air rate attack and all that
college stuff you know is there going to
be enough meat potatoes of that offense
to work in the nfl and my answer would
probably be no there's not but cliff
kingsbury showed me that he was willing
to adapt to the nfl and add a lot of new
things to his offense as the year went
on and that's what i love to see
and that makes me feel good
about their prospects on the offensive
side of the ball can kingsbury continue
to evolve that way or
have we seen the the limitations of you
know the amount of offense he's gonna
put in if that's the case then i would
be i'm a little scared because you know
there's of course he's got studied this
year the defensive coordinators in the
nfc west all got a year to oh wait okay
this is what he did to us last year
here's some tendencies he likes to rely
on this in certain situations you know
he likes to call this in long-yarded
situations they're gonna have a better
feel for him but he's certainly gonna
have a better talent level and to me
what's cool is you know as we're seeing
a lot of offenses in football the 49ers
and most teams almost go the other way
where we're going to run the ball play
this more powerful style of football the
cardinals and chiefs are the opposite
right now they're going
screw that let's just spread out the
field and let our quarterbacks work
magic and that's scary when you think
about isabella runs 4-3 deandre hopkins
superstar running 4-4 larry fitzgerald
okay old man wide receiver you know uh
wise guy yeah not super athletic but we
know he's really good uh and then i'm
missing another receiver i wanted to add
into that christian kirk christian kirk
yeah you add that i mean that's like
that's show time i mean it's like whoa
it's the fast break it's just going to
be kyler murray running around dishing
the ball out and
i'm excited to see that and i think it
is going to make a lot of defensive
coordinators stay up late at night and
squirm a little
how about this chris last year
the cardinals brought the air raid
offense to the nfl in a big big way they
used four receivers in one running back
yeah 32 of the snaps the next highest
team was the seahawks at nine percent
that just says that that tells you now
now how much will they adjust this year
will they use less of it we'll see but
if it works it works shotgun formation
82 of the plays highest in the league
nfl average was 61
and it worked yeah that's the thing and
the the one thing that that continues to
resonate for me they didn't overuse
kyler murray as a runner he can when he
needs to yep when he has to
but they they they are
recognizing something that the ravens
aren't which is you know basic physics
your guy can only take so many hits
before something on him breaks so
they've been very careful with kyle
murray in that regard at least relative
to what other mobile quarterbacks have
done but but you know he's a great
passer that was one of the things and
that's one of the things i miss about
pre-season this year yeah we can't see
what those rookies look like do they
pass the eyeball test i remember
watching i think it was chargers
cardinals their first preseason we knew
it right away
yeah and the ball explodes out of his
hand the ball explodes into the hands of
the receivers he he just immediately
looks the part and we're not gonna know
that for this year's rookies until it's
time to step up and play in the regular
season no it stinks and i remember
watching that game last year and you
know i think we had you know nfl game
pass working or whatever both of us and
yeah i can still remember you texting me
you know after like two two or three
throws you're like oh i'm sold kyler
murray belongs or whatever something
like that but that was really all you
needed to see and you know mike back to
the shotgun air raid all of those things
82 in the shotgun and 32 and four wide
receivers one running back
you know first off uh i'm glad to see
they got underneath the center 18 of the
time i didn't know if cliff kingsbury
was going to be worthy of that so and
they don't need a lot so that was good
to see that they could add that in just
as a little curveball every now and then
but for most teams i would say
this formula is not going to work
shotgun spread it out every play
it's just it's too limited you know
certain defenses are going to match up
well with it the right way schemes you
know you're not gonna be able to keep
people uh you know
respecting the run game but
they can get away with it because of the
quarterback the quarterback you know to
what you said a little mike he's special
and he's gonna make defenses have to be
wary of things okay yeah he hasn't run
the ball in two and a half quarters it
doesn't matter we better still play a
defense where we're accounting for the
run gaps even though they're spread out
because if they call the quarterback
draw this is the type of quarterback
that can go up the sidelines for a
50-yard touchdown so that's the effect
he has and he has an unbelievably strong
arm and an unbelievable quick release
too to where the run game is the quick
screens and the things like that i mean
he's a baseball player like a mahomes
it's just
you it's like he's turning double plays
all the time so that's where it's gonna
be fun to watch and um
uh you know i think it sets up for him
to have a huge statistical year
we will see him in prime time twice this
year there's a thursday night game in
a seattle that uh will be on fox and
then there is a monday night game at
dallas in october and and and a couple
of late afternoon
games that uh you know potentially could
get him some more
exposure than the ordinary would have
i'd like to see him in prime time more
often than that because chris as it
relates to mvp odds he's a 20 to 1
proposition and i think your profile has
a lot to do with uh what your chances
are people need to be seeing you get it
done he's behind patrick mahomes lamar
jackson russell wilson dak prescott and
tom brady would you pick kyler murray as
the potential mvp above any of those
guys say those again just one more time
brady dak prescott holmes yeah
mahomes dak lamar jackson russell wilson
and brady no i'm not going to not that i
don't believe he is mvp caliber player
and can be in that conversation i'm not
going to believe in the cardinals quite
yet i'm not i can't say that i think
they're going to be in the class to put
him in that position like you're saying
you know i just i got to see a little
bit more there's some young talent byron
murphy jr on defense drafting isaiah
simmons freak of nature you know uh some
of those guys like devondre campbell
they get him as a free agent middle
linebacker i got to see a little
improvement out of that defense i got to
see patrick peterson go back to doing
patrick peterson type things in the past
pass game and all that so i i guess it's
the team i'm saying that i don't know if
i necessarily believe in but the good
thing too mike what we always do when we
look at these the early schedule for the
cardinals you know i know week one of
the 49ers that that's going to be rough
and they're not going to be the better
team in the field but washington lions
at panthers at jets i mean there's four
games in a row there that i'm gonna say
at the very least they're equal to those
two three four and five team on their
schedule there to go they're equal and
they'll have a chance to win the game
you know i'm not going to say their
rosters are better than the 49ers of the
cowboys or the seahawks and week seven
yet but i think those other games are
winnable and as we talk about a lot of
the times you win a few games early
young team get a little mojo going you
know you never know where the season can
go after that
and if they come out of those first five
games three and two or better game six
is that monday night game against the
cowboys old nfc east rivals a big
platform an opportunity for kyler murray
to have kind of a coming out party if
they have it rolling those first several
weeks of the ceiling a season rather
that becomes a huge huge game for the
cardinals to kind of put everyone on
notice right definitely that we're we're
here to compete this year and then they
they have uh seattle after that and uh
and then they have their bye week i mean
they they could go into the bye week you
know four and three maybe even five and
two who knows the only two that jump out
as as the the true well three the
troubling games are the 49ers cowboys
and seahawks but they beat the seahawks
in seattle last year so they could go
into their bye week beating seattle and
uh everyone's saying hey watch the
cardinals in the second half of the
season all right best case worst case
for the cardinals this year what do you
got um i i'm not gonna sit here and say
that i believe arizona is a playoff team
yet i don't think i'm gonna go that high
as best case i think best case you know
they're they're flirting as we've said
with some other teams here they're
flirting with the playoffs in december
um maybe have a chance to if you win the
last two games and
team a and b lose you get in i think
that's the best case where i see it like
nine and seven something like that they
just missed out worst case i don't see
it being really horrible either though
you know i'll say maybe six and ten
about as bad as it goes but i think it's
gonna be really exciting football to
watch this year i do there's a lot of
young studs on this team to be excited
to watch and of course with klingsberry
kingsbury and vance joseph as the
offensive defensive coordinators there
i think they got more talent that fits
their scheme here than they did last
year
they play the four teams of the nfc east
to four teams of the afce so what are
you gonna say kind of
they'll kind of get away to get away to
prove my my thought that they'd be
potentially favorites in either of those
divisions i think best case scenario is
five seat i i don't think they're ready
to box out both the seahawks and the
49ers they neither but i could see them
slipping into second place above one of
those two teams in the nfc west and get
themselves in position for that five
spot they still have to go on the road
up to start the postseason but but at
least they'd be in and it's part of that
that building block as they get closer
and closer to becoming a perennial
contender and and i don't want to get
too carried away with a team that hasn't
done anything but part of this job is we
try to spot what's going to happen
before it happens yeah and i just feel
like that this is a team that you're
taking the rise right
the rams the rams are on the decline or
at least they're kind of at a spot where
we don't know which way they're going to
go
i just feel like the cardinals are one
of those teams that is that is beginning
the process of arriving and i say
ten and six five seed worst case
scenario basement of the division six
and ten five and eleven uh but but still
no reason to blow it up you stick with
it for another year yeah and and see
what cliff kingsbury and kyle murray can
do together in 2021 chris yeah i agree
agree with that you know
this is a team that they need another
year or two to get going they're young
they certainly are across the board both
sides of the ball i mean uh but they got
a lot to be excited about certainly but
that is one hell of a division it is i
mean the fact that we're talking the
rams like that just two years out of the
super bowl and barely missed the
playoffs last year it just shows you how
amazing and how good the talent is in
this division
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports